[Music]
okay i have one short question uh uh
which i want a short answer to to
conclude uh our theme too and that is
this does consciousness evolve in
gradients in smooth increments or does
consciousness
evolve in discrete steps something akin
to quanta
short answer from everyone uh start with
michelle no i'm gonna have to i'm gonna
have to defer that answer to ava
okay ava
i think it's a very very difficult
question
my tendency is to think that it is uh
that the in evolutionary biology what we
very often see is a lot of gray areas
and also we see it in development i mean
when we are looking at the processes we
can say well this for example
we can say well this stage of
embryogenesis for example is a blastula
this state of embryogenesis is a
gastronor and so on but in between it's
it's a continuous process and it's very
very difficult to define an evolutionary
biology we always also have these gray
areas so my tendency is to concentrate
on the gray areas because they are very
interesting they we cannot define we we
cannot define things
they are very very clearly but this is
just in some to some extent the joy of
it
you know i think it's it's i tend to
think it's more ground it's it's it's a
gradual process but i do
do realize that there are threshold
effects too in evolution so
you know too little about it
you you have it both ways ian based on
your pan psychism how would you address
that question you say you're pansys but
uh uh
um there is an evolution of
consciousness so given that is it in
discrete aspects or is consciousness a
continuous function well most of the
evolutionary processes we know can move
by quantum leaps and so i would simply
on that basis say that it quite probably
could i mean what one's got to remember
is that when one's talking
in
scientific terms about these incredibly
difficult things to ponder as neil spohr
said we're not actually getting at the
reality itself which we never can what
we're doing is seeing how clearly our
various concepts hang together and that
we're trying to make sense of how our
um concepts hang together the only thing
i would say is that doesn't put me in
the same camp i think as donald who
seems to believe that we our perception
makes no contact with anything outside
this hermetically sealed box in the head
i don't hold that i believe that
everything comes out of an encounter
between our consciousness and the
conscious universe around us don what's
your approach to the uh based on your
approach to consciousness being
fundamental uh does that mean that it's
kind of always there but as evolution
progresses we see it progressing is it
in smooth increments or is it akin to
quantum
well i i take consciousness to be
ontologically fundamental and i'm not a
dualist
so that's all that there is
and the appearance of space and time are
merely qualia within consciousness and
the brain and the head
are merely qualia within consciousness
so consciousness is not trapped inside
the head it creates the head as one of
its simple symbols and the evolution of
consciousness on its own terms i suspect
that the projection of it into the
space-time format may discrete
mathematics may be fine for that but
that qual that consciousness on its own
terms outside of space and time we may
need um you know a left one and higher
kinds of mathematics not not just
discrete mathematics to to to to deal
with it so we know that space time
itself has a finite number of states 10
to the minus 43 seconds and 10 to the
minus 33 centimeters is as far down as
you can go so you don't and that's not
very many digits i mean if it was 10 to
the minus 33 trillion centimeters i'd be
impressed 10 to the minus 33 i'm not
impressed at all so
math
in space and time but consciousness on
its own terms as fundamental we may need
all orders of infinity
so basic basically what what you're
saying is that the question i pose based
on your um uh metaphysics is kind of
irrelevant whether it's smooth or or or
in quantum steps is is is irrelevant
because consciousness is there it's
fundamental so the question makes no
sense in your metaphysics okay look i
can't imagine how conscious responses
can be more efficient as even said than
reflex-like behaviors i agree with that
but i just still cannot imagine how
everybody else has how physical
mutations alone can engender the
required questions of consciousness so
we're gonna go on to theme three
uh will we ever provide an explanation
for consciousness i think i can almost
answer the question from each of you but
i'm gonna let you do it uh and can we
even make progress uh michelle i want
you to weigh the roles of science and
philosophy in explaining consciousness i
know your position but what way each one
because some say that science is the
only way that we can understand that eva
is saying that just like the way we
understand life will understand
consciousness others of course the rest
of the panel uh that science is in
principle self-limited um you're you've
sort of said that but i'm not sure
yeah that definitely uh the latter i i
don't think that we can explain
consciousness in the sense of the origin
of consciousness it's like asking it's
sort of like asking you know why does
matter exist you know we gotta ask god i
don't think we're going to
answer that question i do think we can
make progress
studying consciousness but not
necessarily by looking to science but
rather by looking to phenomenology that
the study of conscious experience as we
have it and by studying and paying very
careful attention to how consciousness
appears to us we might make some
progress in understanding its structure
and develop new concepts to describe it
more adequately so in that sense i do
think we can make progress
okay ian uh you champion the view that
the humanities contribute to human
understanding in ways that the sciences
in principle can never do
to defend this view do you need
consciousness to be any way non-physical
so i'm asking you to take your the
position that that you presented so uh
wonderfully in your books and and ask
whether your sense that consciousness is
a an ontological primitive as as a
pantheist is that a required position in
order to defend the importance of the
humanities
i'm not saying by reading the humanities
you solve the problem of consciousness
i don't think we can come to that at all
um whatever we do
and there are certain things that
science i mean love is a very real
experience and you only know it when
you've had it but it's something that
science can only refer to
um physical correlates of
rather in ineffectively actually um
even that but it's not the same as
knowing what love actually is and the
same is true of consciousness it's a
subjective phenomenon and as such it's
not open to the kind of science um
that that i think is being um required i
think
like michelle i think that a
phenomenological approach is the only
one that will get us in any way closer
but i think that actually we're as close
already as we can get
but your
your view of the importance of the
humanities to human understanding
um
let me just pose if you were convinced
that
consciousness was entirely physical that
eva with our arguments has convinced you
uh
would that change your approach to
humanity i'm trying to see if we can
dissect out your approach to humanities
as as contributes to human understanding
from your sense of what consciousness is
so uh the thought experiment
hypothetically eva has convinced you
that consciousness is 100 physical like
life is physical would that affect your
approach to humanities
well it's a it's a big counter factual
but
it wouldn't have affected my approach
because
in the end
what one knows about the humanities it's
from experience and what one knows is
that it enormously enriches one's
consciousness without it when
one is aware of an experience is
less that's a rich world so it's part of
the enrichment of experiences to is to
take in these elements
which which give you
if nothing else they give you some
skepticism about what science can answer
i mean i'm a huge
don't get me wrong i'm not saying you
know i i i'm always defending science
because i am a scientist and i've
benefited from it all my life but it
can't answer all our questions this is
just the kind of question it can't
answer don you believe that science can
never make progress never within a
materialist physicalist framework but if
you start with consciousness as your
ontological primitive isn't your
conclusion just your premise
what well
no so
with with a theory in which
consciousness is fundamental uh you have
to have a specific dynamics that you
write down and you have to show how
space and time quantum field theory
general relativity and evolution of
natural selection come out as a special
projection of that deeper theory if i
cannot do that then there's no reason to
take my theory seriously so there's
there are strong conditions scientific
theoretical conditions on on the claim
that consciousness is fundamental if you
cannot predict scattering amplitudes at
the large hadron collider your theory
should not be taken seriously so that's
what we have to do i i say you have a
long uh long road ahead of you uh even
uh yeah not before lunch i just want to
say
i'm not and
neither myself nor anybody who knows any
uh any neuroscience is a naive realist
so
it's not as if we're not aware
it's phenomenology is uh absolutely as a
is part and parcel
of the view of the of my view and
most scientists that i know view of what
reality is
there is a very famous uh
i what is we cannot understand the way
that i see it is that we that
consciousness
occurs
like most things in this world in their
realm of interactions the interactions
between some aspects of the world
some as uh some aspects of the brain and
some aspects of receptors that we have
of the body
okay there is a very famous there is a
very famous haiku
that says uh
oh green green willow wonderfully red
flower but i know the colors are not
there
and of course the colors are not there
they are they are not there
independently of the brain they are not
there independently of the receptors and
they are not there independently
of of of some properties of the physical
world the third third person knowledge
can be becomes first-person knowledge
only if we implement it within our
brains i always conclude consciousness
uh discussions the the same way while
i'm
always appreciating more and more of the
deeper and richer issues and questions
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas